Star Wars Jedi Fallen order packs a lot
of story into its 15-hour campaign from
run-ins with Jedi hunting inquisitors
and space-faring gamblers with forearms
to encounters with giant space bird
things it has a dense narrative that
straddles a lot of Star Wars lore and
the odd Cameo this is Master Obi-Wan
Kenobi and while we're only really one
game deep into the franchise it's still
well worth getting a little refresher on
the story so whether you played the
original game back in 2019 and want to
story recap for Star Wars Jedi Survivor
or maybe you're here because you want to
know how Jedi Fallen order slots into
the Canon timeline let's break down the
story so far
Star Wars Jedi Fallen order takes place
in the year 14 BBY which but simply
means 14 years before the Battle of
Yavin IV a battle that culminated with
the Epic destruction of the Death Star
seen in Star Wars Episode 4 A New Hope
it's also about five years since the
chilling events of episode 3 Revenge of
the Sith and the execution of Order 66
The galaxy-wide Purge of the Jedi so
with that all in your mind Fallen order
kicks off with young Jedi and hiding
calkestis on the scrapyard planet of
bracca a former Padawan Cal has
successfully evaded the Empire and their
inquisitors former Jedi's turned Jedi
Hunters until his mate prayoff nearly
dies during an accident at work and Cal
has to use his Jedi force powers to save
him and for anyone who's seen the
Obi-Wan Kenobi Telly show as soon as the
Jedi is prompted into saving an innocent
life little false alarm Bells start
going with the inquisitors and lo and
behold the inquisitor's second and Ninth
sisters turn up moments later to claim
their Jedi bounty in order to save his
work colleagues Prof gives himself up as
the Jedi Outcast but when the
inquisitors see through his sacrifice
they promptly murder him which leads to
cow blowing his cover
the young Jedi escapes bracket by the
skin of his teeth but not without help
from a pair of mysterious Travelers in
the form of seer gender and griez dritas
who appear pretty much out of nowhere in
their ship the Mantis and whisk Callaway
to an old Jedi Sanctuary on the planet
of bagano
and it's here where the plot of Jedi
Fallen order really starts to take shape
we learned that sear was also once a
Jedi but that she's locked herself off
from the force for mysterious reasons
she needs Kel's help to access an
ancient Vault built by a race known as
the zepho A vault only accessible to
those strong in the force naturally Cal
is a little hesitant to take up the
whims of a complete stranger but after
the day he's had he says and I'm
paraphrasing here yeah sure what the
hell why not this turns out to be the
best decision he's ever made as it leads
him straight into the path of the most
adorable Droid in the galaxy bd1
with BD in tow the pair head off for the
vault with Kyle remembering how to wall
run along the way as this is a respawn
game and it's contractually obliged I'm
being incredibly glib there as these
lessons are actually framed as little
flashbacks to when Cal was a Padawan in
the Jedi Order training with his master
jarrow to Paul a Jedi from the lasatres
the same race as Star Wars Rebels fan
favorite severellius at the full medium
veils a holographic message from an old
Jedi Master known as Edo Cordova which
states that he's hidden a Jedi holocron
with a list of four sensitive children
within the Vault the catch well Cal
needs to travel to three zephoto tombs
spread across the Galaxy because let's
not forget this is a video game and we
need places to explore
from Pagano the game branches out into
several more Worlds the first is the
zepho Homeworld and the second is
dathomir which fans of the Clone Wars
animated series will undoubtedly know as
the home of the creepy night sisters as
well as the birthplace of one Darth Maul
I am surprised you could have forgotten
me so easily which should give you some
indication that it's perhaps not the
friendliest place in the galaxy
if you're like me you probably opted for
dathomir to get that sweet double-bladed
lightsaber while dying a fair few times
at the hands of the Knight Brothers in
the process if that sounds like you
chances are you probably also met the
night sister Marin as well as a
mysterious Wanderer who claims to be
searching for zepho ruins on the planet
don't forget this creepy lad as he'll be
cropping up later on as dathomir
presents nothing but dead ends at this
stage the Mantis Cruise next Port of
Call is the Windswept wastes of zepho
where it turns out the Empire have been
very busy with an aborted mining project
known as project auger naturally they're
still knocking about insignificant
numbers but that doesn't stop Cal and BD
venturing deep into the bowels of the
planet to discover one of those fo tombs
Cordova has been banging on about in
this diet Zelda dungeon Cal relearns his
Force push ability while BD discovers
another holographic message from Cordova
which points them in the direction of
The Wookie Homeworld of kashyyk and
their Chieftain tarful who was a close
friend of Cordova's
[Music]
landing on kashyyk is something of a
problem though as the Mantis crew find
themselves in the middle of a raging
battle between the Empire the wookies
and a group of Freedom Fighters led by
grizzled War veteran saw Guerrera seen
here nearly 15 years before his fateful
part and the theft of the Death Star
plans in Rogue one unable to land Carl
and BD take a plunge into the Waters of
kashyyk and hijack their way onto an
8080. in an awesome sequence that's
equal parts Uncharted and Shadow of the
Colossus after taking out an entire
platoon of Stormtroopers Carl and the
Mantis teen rendezvous with saw and his
insurgents who are in the middle of
relinquishing a sap Refinery from Empire
Control Cal agrees to help in the hope
of finding the whereabouts of tarful who
is absolutely nowhere to be found once
they take the refinery back and free the
enslaved Wookies
just as he's about to venture deeper
into the rainforest of kashyyk sear
urgently drags him back to the Mantis
after receiving word that the Empire are
close to discovering another tomb back
on zepho the crew rushed back to zfo to
beat the Empire to the punch but it's a
trap well it's true that that the Empire
discovered a second zepho tomb the
message Sierra seed was a trap laid by
the second sister who ambushes Cal and
shock twist reveals herself to be Sia's
former Jedi Padawan triller after a
fierce battle in which Cal is completely
out of his depth he manages to escape
Trilla only through the timely
intervention of your palamine bd1
escaping into the second zephotume the
tomb of mctrol Carl and BD start
scouring the ancient ruins for any clues
left behind by Cordova on their jolly
old way their ambushed by trailer for a
second time in the span of half an hour
which is just bad form for a Jedi they
should be able to sense this sort of
stuff either way they managed to escape
while Cal relearns another Jedi
technique This Time Force pull and Billy
discovers another encrypted log from Eno
Cordova which explains that the key to
the Pagano vault is something known as
the zepho Austrian but on their way
off-world the pair run into a spotted
bother in the form of a bounty hunter
foreign
[Music]
jail in an unknown Place hell even in an
unknown system turns out he's in the
lair of the infamous haxian brood a
cartel of mobsters who kidnap Cal to get
to the mantis's pilot grease who's
racked up a pretty penny a debt in his
time between this and Sears withholding
of her ties to the second sister I'd be
pretty pissed off if I was count he
takes his anger out on a veritable
menagerie of beasts laid on for him by
The haxian Brood in a gladiator-like
Coliseum this batch of bloodthirsty
entertainment is put on hold when the
Mantis crash lands right into the middle
of the Arena to rescue Cal back aboard
the Mantis Cal lays into Seer about well
everything but their squabble is cut
short by a transmission from kashyyk
with the supposed location of tarful
Landing again on The Wookie Homeworld
Cal and Beady Venture their way through
kashyyk's shadowlands to the last known
location of The Wookie Chieftain where
they finally finally catch up with him
he immediately sends them on their way
to the origin tree basically a big
sacred Evergreen for the wookies where
they encountered
bird after a tussle between the Shire
bird and the ninth sister's ship
calombidi nursed the giant bird back to
health and for their troubles they get a
lift right to the top of the tree which
is handily where they want to be
[Music]
foreign at the top they discovered that
Cordova has found an Atrium years before
and that there might just be another one
in a zephoto tomb back on dathomir but
before they can hightail it back to the
world of the night sisters the ninth
sister oof that's uh confusing ambushes
the pair and kicks off another boss
battle found you again you're done
hurting this world Cal now the little
experience fighting inquisitors under
his belt manages to dispatch the
knight's sister by force pushing her
right off the top of the tree have that
and with that the pair hitch a lift with
the shirebird back to the Mantis and
their next destination of dathomir
right back to dathomir the story takes
us on a rather lengthy diversion through
the bowels of this wonderfully
hospitable planets on route to the zepho
temple Cal and BD are not only ambushed
by the Knight Brothers again but by
Marin who unleashes a horde of Undead
night sisters on the unwitting pair
before the kudagrass in the form of the
dreaded gorgara a giant winged bat
dragon thing that hunts the pair through
the Skies of dathomir regardless of the
Perils of this Scenic detour the pair
finally make it to the zepho temple
where Cal encounters a dark force vision
of his old Jedi Master Jared to Pal who
overpowers his former apprentice and
destroys the young Jedi's lightsaber in
the process
and former Jedi Masters are like London
buses it seems as soon as he's able to
escape the zepho temple Kell bumps back
into the creepy Wanderer from earlier
who reveals himself to be Taron malakus
a former Jedi who has now become
something of a wrongen by studying the
dark side of the force before he can
recruit Cal into his nefarious plans
he's interrupted by Merin who literally
raises hell in her attempts to destroy
them both Kell without a lightsaber to
defend himself escapes back to the
Mantis through sheer luck and having
been through an emotional and physical
roller coaster he immediately opens up
to Seer about his traumatic experience
of Order 66 which he also escaped by the
skin of his teeth his former Master
Jared tapal wasn't as lucky it turns out
and Carol has blamed himself for his
death ever since with his lightsaber in
tatters Seer gifts Cal her own Hilt and
charts a course for the planet of illum
where young Jedi padawans used to visit
to find kyber crystals for their first
lightsabers it's the choice to keep
fighting
makes us who we are
foreign
ing on the ice Planet Carl and Beady
ventured deep into a set of caves that
laid out from an ancient Jedi Temple
with the kyber crystal calling out to
him Cal makes his way towards it only
for the ice beneath him to shatter
throwing him into an icy pool he saved
by the ever-reliable BD who stallied up
a fair few rescues of cow by this point
but the kyber crystal isn't so lucky
splitting into two pieces Cal armed with
both his Old Masters lightsaber and
Sears combines them both with the two
Crystal pieces to create a
Frankenstein's monster of a weapon that
could be single bladed double-bladed and
dual wielded which is just having your
cake and eating it if you ask me
[Music]
with a flashy new weapon and a newfound
sense of purpose Kell Journeys back to
dathomir to face evil jarrow to Pal once
again and this time defeats him by well
doing nothing that's a gross
simplification because he's obviously
doing Jedi stuff but you know what I
mean after defeating gyro Kell and BD
enter the zepho temple and encounter
Marin once again who seems a little bit
more receptive to talking than before
the pair bond Around The Morbid topic
that they've both survive massacres of
their respective people Cal with the
Jedi during Order 66 and Marin with
General Grievous's Slaughter of the
night sisters back during the Clone Wars
this combined with the fact that
countless Taran malakus sees bear inside
with the young Jedi and become a
powerful Ally for the Mantis crew and
she makes the support known with her
part in dispatching Taran in battle
moments later
with the Wayward Jedi a thing of the
past Cal and Marin Venture forth into
the temple to secure the Austrian and
with that in the bag the Mantis crew set
sail for Pagano and the Zephyr Vault you
found it oh who's this
what's that supposed to mean it means
I'll be joining you back at the ball Cal
uses the atrium to secure the Jedi
holocron but is immediately thrust into
a vision of the Empire's Purge of Jedi
younglings snapping out of the vision
Cal comes face to face with Trilla once
again and this time he's able to
overpower her but in the process of
nabbing her lightsaber Cal is swept up
into yet another Vision this time
spurred on by the darkness in triller's
weapon and this vision is nearly as
brutal as the last detailing trillis
capture and torture at the hands of the
Empire as well as her master Sears
Escape while Cal is on his Jedi Mind
trip Trilla escapes with the holocron
back to the inquisitors HQ The Fortress
inquisitorious which is basically a
giant space castle in the middle of a
vast ocean it's not exactly a cheery
Place kale comes too and hightails it
back to the crew and the newly formed
quintet decide to chase after the
holocron using some Nifty Space Magic
courtesy of bona fide space witch Marin
they are able to slip by the brace of
Star Destroyers protecting the
inquisitor's base and get down to the
planet there in a sequence that the
Obi-Wan Kenobi show liberally Rift on
Carl and sear Infiltrate The Bass
confront trailer and take the holocron
back by force so far so easy but where's
that heavy breathing coming from oh yeah
it's the devil under a suit of metal
himself Darth Vader who's decided to
join the fight he promptly murders
Trilla In Cold Blood before Force
flinging Seer to her supposed death
Carol the cocky fool that he is puts up
a wholehearted fight before realizing
yeah maybe I'm a little out of my depth
here he makes a run for it escaping
Vader's attacks by the barest of all
margins and is finally rescued by Seer
who uses the force for the first time in
like forever to stall Vader's attacks
Cal repays the favor by attempting to
flood Vader at the bottom of the
inquisitor's base of operations while
Vader's holding back the flood Cal and
Seer Escape With a Little Help from
Merin and finally back aboard the Mantis
with the Jedi holocron secure in their
possession Cal makes the executive
decision to destroy it and the knowledge
of the whereabouts of the Galaxy's Force
sensitive children so where to now
well some of the where to now is
actually answered in the tie-in novel
Battle Scars which takes place between
Fallen order and Survivor the book
largely Chronicles the Misadventures of
the Mantis crew in their attempts to
secure a cloaking device known as the
Shroud as well as its creator from
Imperial control it's a fun little read
that explains some of the visual details
that will be seen in Survivor notably
cow's facial scar and the backstory as
to why gries now has a robotic arm and
with that bring on Star Wars Jedi
Survivor thanks so much for watching
this story recap guys I hope you enjoyed
it and I like me looking forward to
seeing where the story goes next thanks
a lot guys I'll see you next time